[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones is now halfway
through season eight and after an
incredibly epic battle with the night
king the White Walkers are finally
vanquished however that doesn't mean
that winter is finally over
and with Cersei mounting her golden
company it seems like her armies are in
the perfect position to take over
Winterfell the trailer for episode 4 has
just dropped and there's a lot to unpack
from it throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the preview and what the
show could have in store for the future
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
without the way thank you for clicking
this video I hope you enjoy it now sit
back relax and let's get into my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 4 preview
breakdown
we have won the great pool now we will
win the last war
we'll rip her out fruit and stem the
trailer opens with Circe overseeing her
brand-new army the golden company whilst
she never got to get some of her
elephants these guys are still some of
the best fighters in E sauce and
therefore they will be a pretty big
match for the recently decimated forces
of Westeros Cersei has spies everywhere
so now she no doubt knows of the huge
losses that Westeros has taken and this
is why she's readying her forces for the
attack you Ron stands behind her and
while Cersei seems like the master
manipulator in the show I actually have
a feeling that you Ron is the one who's
really in control
he's pretty much almost puppeteering
Cersei in this shot so it definitely
symbolizes to me that he's the one
behind a lot of this from here we get
the aftermath of the big battle of
Winterfell from episode 3 it seems like
people are trying to rebuild the area
and Daenerys states that they've won the
Great War and now they win the last one
this of course means that they are now
going head to head with Cersei and her
forces Daenerys is clearly ready for a
fight as she's pretty much unbeaten at
this point and to me the most important
thing about her statement is the
arrogance behind it
Daenerys believes that when she wins it
will be the last ever war and with her
at the helm there will be nothing but
peace this is of course a bold statement
and suggests that Dany isn't fully aware
enough of the lands to properly control
them should she get into power as we all
know there will be more complex even
after the throne is secured she's slowly
turning into a father for me and
statements like this confirm it
personally I think that the Starks are
like this happen but deep down they know
that if they get the opportunity they
will take the throne from her
bear in mind now that Dany has very few
forces left with the unsullied being
almost wiped out so I don't think his
spot on the throne is as confirmed as
she thinks it is we then get a couple of
quick cuts Dany is with a dragon we then
see her flying over a bow which could be
her naval force that we see later in the
trailer Arya is kissing Gendry and the
funeral pyres are lit Iran looks like
he's proposing and John and Davos right
out now this could involve them
attempting to talk to Cersei in order to
stop the conflict before more lives are
lost however I don't think this will go
down well as we see Cersei
almost smoking with you run behind her
once more
so what could happen to Circe and will
they manage to defeat her well there's a
very strong indication in episode 3 that
area may be the one to do it
we already know that she has Circe on a
list and when talking with one another
Alessandra told her in season 3 brown
eyes blue eyes green eyes I sealed shut
forever we will meet again this was
hinting at the fact that Aria would
murder many people before their next
encounter and the line hangs heavily
over the most recent episode the blue
eyes of course mean the night king but
the green eyes to me at least means
Circe who is the only character that can
think of in the show that has them
obviously this double whammy of villains
for Arya is going to be big news and it
could even seal her spot on the throne
perhaps if she decides to hook up with
Gendry properly the two could become
king and queen though I can imagine that
and knowing a lot of fans but hey it
won't be the first time that Game of
Thrones has done something to irritate
people obviously we'll find out if this
happens in the rest of the season but I
can definitely see this as a possibility
going forward I'd of course love to hear
your thoughts on the preview and if you
agree with my Cersei theory comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then make sure you give it a
thumbs up and check out my breakdown of
episode 3 which will be linked at the
end this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]